ma come si sta bene testare i dettagli
oggi il nuovo episodio in cui proverei
trucchetti per nascondere gli snack al
cinema dal controllore questo è l'ultimo
episodio purtroppo le roste questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace ci sarà
anche un altro episodio bono adesso di
un bel mi piace oggi proverò dei
trucchetti super super fa quasi alla
fine del video come sempre dovrete
scrivere nei commenti qual è stato il
vostro trucchetto preferito il vostro
momento preferiti in più alla fine del
video si sarà un quiz per voi quindi
guardate il video fino alla fine e poi
rispondete pure alle domande del quiz se
volete che avete visto l'episodio
presidente sapete che il controllore ha
una nuova arma
lo scanner per di snack body scanner
quindi questa volta dovremo stare molto
attenti mettetevi comodi se non vi
seguite ancora senza g andati a seguirmi
l'amenità stories se volete seguitemi
anche tu tic toc rende tipo corno il tè
caldo
mettetevi comodi e iniziamo con il primo
trucchetto da tantissimo ho preso
qualcosa di speciale per il primo
trucchetto e penso che il controllore
non se ne accorgerà spero tra dovuto
perché cos'è secondo voi questo penso
che avete indovinato tantissime
caramelle ma cosa c'è di strano in
queste caramelle non sono caramelle
normali ma sono quelle caramelle che si
possono mettere come collana o come
bracciale o come cintura nostre
tantissime
che carino wow
mi ricordo sempre che da piccolo le
volevo tanto ma non li ho mai avute
queste collane che si mangiano e li
avete mai mangiate queste collane con le
caramelle e allora questo potrebbe
essere un bracciale non se ne accorgerà
mai spero potrei mettermi un sacco
magari per questa volta proviamo solo la
collana ho paura che altrimenti con il
body scanner se n'è accorto ma se per un
altro episodio mi riempirò di queste
collane caramelle guerdat e fuma di
vaniglia ora andiamo proviamo
intrufolarsi al cinema e speriamo che il
controllore non se ne accorga che c'è
biglietto e che trovo molto bene
ora però facciamo la perquisizione
bufala come ben sa niente cibo in sala
ma padrino hanno portato adesso ne siamo
sicuri o scanner sembra non rivelare al
principe mero sospetto nel suo caso bene
quindi se non hai trovato ai piedi che
possa andare dove che può passare allora
questa volta però è troppo
[Musica]
questo profumo di fragola vaniglia
caramello ce l'abbiamo fatta
se non riuscite a intrappolare la mia
collana caramelle ora possiamo mangiare
la nostra caramelle ma fatta pensando a
rita impazzita sta mangiando le collare
adesso prossimo il trucchetto cosa userò
per il prossimo trucchetto un peluche un
topo un parrucchino
se siete quasi berlino è salito sul
tavolo sta cercando di mangiare né
collane caro ma è una parrucca siete
pronti a vedermi con un altro colore di
capelli perché dove lo avete consigliato
voi avete detto un messicano parrucca e
bt snack dentro alla parrucca o sotto
alla parrucca non so se funzionerà
proviamo a nembro tipo granny però
giovane ok proviamo prima con dei
cioccolatini
dentro alla parrucca così sarà
impossibile per il controllore trovarle
proviamo reame truccate 5 questo posso
nasconderlo sotto i capelli visto che
sono tantissimi i capelli
secondo me ci cascherà andiamo emilietta
per caso cambiato colore di capelli di
recente di questo è un po sospetto
che strano e quando qualcosa qualcosa
qui sono solo i suoi capelli questi è
anche la madonna e sequestrata crede di
ingannare me con questa parrucca
chissà come mista mi sto proprio bene
questa parrucca sequestrata questi quasi
mela tempo buffa il controllore mi ha
sequestrato la parrocchia
proviamo con il prossimo trucchetto rete
ma il trucchetto per questo trucchetto
farò finta che oggi sia il mio
compleanno mi metterò il cappellino
ovviamente nascondere di snack qua
dentro
nel cappellini cosa possiamo nascondere
che dentro vi diamo un bel po di cose e
cioccolatini ove vi verdot e dove ok ci
sono riuscita ragazzi ho messo il
cappello con tutti gli snack dentro ora
devo andare molto molto piano evitare
che cadano anche perché se non si rompe
tutto andiamo
[Musica]
ma non c'è nessuno non c'è il
controllore
meglio così almeno potrò passare senza
nessun controllo
che cosa sta facendo bene la mia
parrocchia non sono i miei capelli
questi sono cresciuti
va beh posso entrare nel come detto
prima il controllo grazie del biglietto
controllo iscrizione come mondo sono
cappello perché il mio compleanno in
tanti auguri a te il biglietto a metà
sanitari no nessuno né ci sono riuscita
finita ancora tutto qua lucchetto
riuscito passiamo ora al prossimo
progetto per un altro che sto questo
trucchetto lo stesso lo avete
consigliato voi voi siete super furbi
super intelligenti infatti continuate
consigliare i trucchetti dei commenti in
questo trucchetto semplicemente
attaccherò degli snack quelli più
leggeri sotto alla gomma
ecco qua il cioccolatino l'attacco dopo
che porta a casa cioccolatini alla gamba
devo stare attento a lungo primi troppo
altrimenti cadranno se ne accorgerà
andiamo
buonasera e anche posso entrare non lo
so nasconda qualcosa attaccarlo 16 del
cibo delle bevande
faccio una volta si giri ma c'è una
giravolta molto bene qui parterre non
sbaglio tutto quanto era molto bene ma
purtroppo questo trucchetto della donna
non è riuscito ma il prossimo trucchetto
penso che riuscirà perché è molto
divertente ma faccio vedere subito via
prossimo trucchetto vi ricordate in uno
degli scorsi episodi in un trucchetto
che ha funzionato molto bene che vi è
piaciuto tantissimo
ero mettere la cloche qua nella pancia
come se fossi incinta e nascondere tutti
gli snack dentro ho pensato un altro
trucchetto e cioè l'annuncio fa jobs
gigante lo nascondere una stessa nella
pancia sperando che non ci caschi anche
se questo è un po più piccolo rispetto
alla croce ci sono già lisma extra
speriamo che ci fa schifo stessi
problema è questo lo stesso del suo
bacio come faccio a nasconderlo ok
andiamo e speriamo che tutte accorga di
niente
si sta nascondendo qualcosa
no no non sta nascondendo niente eppure
lo scanner tutti titolo qualcosa proprio
qui che cosa prima di uscire ma già
tantissimi dolci e fellini sono rimasti
in cui immagini va bene lo sa che una
volta anche adesso successo la stessa
cosa
ho mangiato talmente dantisti che era
venuta una pancia enorme
peccato però che non è andata più via
prego si accomodi se volesse di
intrappolare il lecca lecca gigante
questo trucchetto è riuscito e ora pure
time per voi che siete arrivati fino
alla fine del video ecco il quiz
composto da tre domande dovete
rispondere alle tre domande giù nei
commenti qui saranno sempre relativi
alla serie di video attuale quindi in
questo caso alla serie di video dei
trucchetti degli snack se non li avete
visti tutti andate a vederli tutti dopo
questo video domanda numero on dove ha
nascosto gli snack merlino in questa
serie dei trucchetti degli snack
scrivetemi come domanda numero due in
quale episodio ho usato la cloche con
gli snack dentro
scrivetelo giu nei commenti domanda al
numero 3 in quale episodio ho attaccato
di snack al guinzaglio di merlino scrivi
nei commenti scrivete le vostre risposte
dei commenti vediamo in quanti riusciti
ad azzeccare tutte le risposte
ora vi lascio qua 4 castellina se
pubblicare proprio dei ridotti altri
video cliccate su quelli che preferite e
buono
ciao
[Musica]